the hard work that I saw my dad put into
Chinese food makes me feel really proud
proud that I was lucky enough to learn
from my master I want people to Value it
the same way that I do so what is the
value of Chinese food is it the taste is
it the hard work and the training or is
it the dishes history and the Nostalgia
makes us feel to me it is all of those
things but the value of Chinese food is
often compared to fast food quick and
cheap
although we've spent years developing
skills to cook faster Chinese food isn't
fast food
it requires skills Mastery of
ingredients and nostalgia
cooking represents all the hard work and
memories that we had learning the art
mastering the skills and understanding
the history of Chinese food so the next
time you visit a Chinese restaurant just
remember
it's not just a plate of fried rice
it's so much more than that